gorillas are the largest of all primates
standing nearly six feet tall and
weighing 400 pounds an adult male has
the strength of several men gorilla
troops are normally shy and peaceful but
the dominant male called a silverback
will defend his territory if provoked
using grunts and chest nothing a
silverback attempts to intimidate
newcomers if that fails to impress
he drops on all fours and charges this
team of scientist is trying to
obituaries to humans but they approach
too quickly and the gorillas react with
frightening speed
I know what girls are coming everywhere
I just just find out as quickly as I
could but it seemed like every every
direction I lock there was a chorale
coming out and then I saw him back down
and I was like home ducking back back
down with them that was me
if a gorilla charges what should you do
should you a run be crouched down or see
thump your chest the correct answer is
beef crouched down running and chest
thumping can provoke an attack causing
serious injuries by slowly crouching
down and averting your eyes your body
language tells the gorilla you are not a
threat to him gorilla charges are mostly
Bluff at the last moment the silverback
usually will veer off before making
contact and no one gets hurt and that's
how you survive a gorilla charge